Hello? I'm Jad Abumrad
and I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is radio lab today our
program is lost and found
approaching zone without
gps. Alright, well you know,
I think we're getting real close on the,
you're driving into our next
adventure is our producer Tim Howard.
See if this is it. So I
sort and I took a trip.
I need your picture id yet
to Fort Monmouth, New Jersey.
For what? Fort Monmouth. Is
that a military base? Yup.
We were going to this
museum they have on the base
to meet this woman Mindy Mindy rose,
what's on the museum curator
at a US army communications.
She agreed to show us around to see what
well um, patients. Chad, do you
wanna hear some stories? Absolutely.
Okay. Here on display
we have the war heroes.
So she pointed to this one glass
case, sorta like a memorial. Well,
he was born in 1918,
died here at Fort Monmouth in
1937. So he lived about 20 years,
served with the army expeditionary forces.
He was wounded and blinded in one eye,
carrying a very important message.
W what's all this on his, on his
face there? Looks like putty.
Like what's all this stuff on his nose?
It's called crop and it's
a natural growth. Um,
I think it's a calcium growth
and some pigeons just get that.
Did she just say pigeons? You've
got it. I'm a lot of forget it.
There's another one
marker for pigeon here.
Oh Wow. Wait a second,
Tim. What's the story?
Why Pigeons? Why Pigeons? Yeah.
Well a pigeons are awesome. And B,
there's a big question here, which is,
well, let me, let me just start you off.
Training wheels with a simple
little story on, this is GI Joe.
He's our hero pigeon, but there's one
pigeon named GI Joe GI Joe is pretty cool.
Well he looks like a totally ordinary
vision. I wouldn't know that.
I'm standing a foot away from
a war hero. I think he's cute.
He's got yellow legs. Remember I told
you about the legs? The feet. All right,
so what's the story? Okay, so
it's 1943 there was a town,
the British have just taken this
little Italian town, Cola, Chia,
Chia from the Germans. The bad guys.
The problem is it took it really fast
and their American allies are about to
bomb the town 20 minutes.
Oh, the radio is there down.
They can't get anybody back to the base
in time to tell them to call it off.
How near bias the space 20 miles away
and so they only really have one option.
Let me guess. No Way. Just so you
really get this. Yeah, bring it home.
This bird is in a place that he's never
been before. Hallway there for hours.
He's been in a dark box. He should
be completely confused. Should be,
and yet when they take them
out and throw them in the air
[inaudible] like a cosmic zip court. He's
pulled over mountains, lakes, forest,
none of which has ever
seen before. Right back
[inaudible]
did the army base where he
lives just in the nick of time,
just as Obama bombers
are about to take off.
He's credited with saving
over a thousand British live
American hatched GI Joe Kennedy,
the message through an
artillery bombardment in Italy
and the same units of the
56 London division.
How the hell did he do that? How
did he know exactly where to go?
Some of them returned with um,
the message capsule hanging from their
leg and their breastbone shot open and
all that kind of stuff. But
they would always fly back home.
How that's your question? Yep.
Hello? Hello there. So I called
this guy. This is Charlie won't get,
he's a heavy hitter in the vision world.
Former director of the Cornell lab
of ornithology. My question is,
if JIEDDO had never been to that town,
how did he know how to
get back home? Well,
the first thing that GI Joe needs
to know is we're wait, wait,
Tim, I'm sorry.
Feel bad for saying this because it's
your first piece for the show. But I mean,
don't we know the answer to this?
What's the answer, John? Well,
birds have a compass in their
head. That's how they migrate. Jed.
You dummy,
you're just not getting the degree of
difficult. Think about it this way.
If I take you on a little boat and put
you out in the middle of a large body of
water, all you can see is
water. And every direction.
Which way do you paddle to find New
York City? Are you asking me? Yeah.
Can I have a compass in this scenario?
Sure. But that's not going to help you.
Sure will. No, no. What do you
mean? No, and just think about it.
W which way are you going to paddle first?
Hmm. I
don't know enough to say exactly.
It depends a little bit on whether
I've dumped you in the Atlantic Ocean,
the Pacific Ocean, the
Indian Ocean or whatever.
You can't swim home if you don't
know which direction home is.
And you're saying this
is what a pigeon does.
You can throw it anywhere and
it knows. That's my whole point.
I W if you were a pigeon, I wouldn't
need to tell you anything. Huh?
How did GI Joe figure out where
he is with relation to home?
That's the great question. That it, okay,
I'm with you now and I'm
sorry for interrupting you
earlier. That's all right.
So how do they do it? Well, and if
you have a one sentence answer for it,
then that's a short interview. It is a
very, very easy answer. We don't know.
Wow.
But they have been doing a lot of crazy
experiments on pigeons over the years,
like 60 years now to try and
figure all this out. Like what? Um,
let us count the ways we have tried flying
pigeons with frosted contact lenses.
They've put coils on their heads
with the pigeons head, like a hat.
They've glued little brass
weights to their backs.
They put radio transmitters
on them. Yes, indeed.
They've followed pigeons and airplanes.
The point is that it is a complex issue
and they have definitely not arrived to
any consensus for how pigeons do this.
They have theories, plenty of theories.
For example, you get talions poppy and his
colleagues believed that when
you take the pigeons out, uh,
to the release point,
they sample the odors on the
way to the release point.
All the smells of the places
that they pass, right?
Essentially a series of all
factory landmarks, you know,
you go past the chocolate factory and
the olive groves of the garlic plantation
or whatever sounds like a beautiful place.
And so when a a pigeon is released, uh,
what it does is it sniffs the breeze
and says, Aha, continue past garlic,
take a left at chocolate.
This is the odor that came to me on the
Northwind and therefore I need to fly
south in order to get home. [inaudible]
but Charlie's actually put this idea to
the test or we anesthetize the pigeons,
put them in a box,
artificial air so they can't smell
anything and are rotating turntable and
transported them to a release
side about a hundred miles away.
And when they got over being kind of
carsick they flew home just fine to
something else is going on here. Yeah.
And here's where we get to my
personal favorite theory. All right.
Forget about smell.
There are some researchers here in the
u s who think that the key to pigeon
navigation, is he ready for this? Yeah.
What is it? Metal
[inaudible],
which is to say if you go all the way
down into the center of the earth,
there's all this iron down there
churning and as it's churning,
it's throwing off this magnetism. Yes.
Lines of magnetic force up
through the earth, out into space.
So imagine up there in the
atmosphere above the planet,
there are all these lines
that are wiggling and as GI
is flying through the air,
he's moving through these lines.
[inaudible]
do you think he sees the lines? Well,
I can tell you that he might feel them
because there are these little particles
in his beak magnetite
magnetic iron particles.
They're twitching in some spots
that twitch more in some spots less.
And if you can measure various
aspects of the magnetic field,
like its strength and its angle,
you can tell whereabouts you are.
Do you think that's
what's actually happening?
I think it may be partly what's
happening. I mean Charlie had,
Charlotte says there's probably a lot of
things going down and anytime you think
you've figured it out, the pigeon
goes and messes you up. For example,
he told me about this one
place, the place in New York,
about 90 miles west of here
called Jersey Hell fire tower.
If we take Cornell pigeons to
Jersey Hill and let them go,
they go random. Uh, and only about
10% of them ever find their way home.
And so they are essentially lost.
It is a Bermuda Triangle
for Cornell pigeons.
Why would that be? That's sorry I
hadn't, if we, I would tell you,
is it a magnetic thing? No, no,
there's nothing magnetically
disturbed about it. Is it a,
a sewage treatment capital? No.
Hyper active radio frequencies? No,
it's a, it's a hill. A surrounded
by pine trees. It's just a hill.
Does it make you wonder if there's a
whole other system going on in a pigeon
that we haven't even started
to think about? Yes, of course.
And then use you say, well what
could it possibly be? Yeah.
And after a long day of being out there
with the pigeons and releasing them and
waiting for them to make up their mind
and fly home and get the vanishing
bearings, you come back and you open
the loft and there they are, you know,
all sitting on their little
purchasers going, cool, cool.
And you just long to grab one by
the scruff of the neck and say,
how do you do it? But so far,
obviously they haven't told us.
[inaudible] one more thing I didn't
tell you about how they were monogamous.
The pigeon mind might be unknowable,
but the patient heart
is an open book. Yeah.
Well Mindy said that with a lot of
other birds, stirs and chickens.
He'd get them all together.
They all go wild and party.
One thing leads to another,
they love Jacuzzi. Right?
Well maybe they go into
Jacuzzi after, maybe they,
I don't know what they do in the
Jacuzzi. I'm not judging, but pigeons,
they would mate and they would stay
mated until death do they part.
So one thing you can do to make the pigeon
fly home faster is you take the male
out of his cage,
you put another male in there with his
girl and of course he's going to get
pissed off. Feathers are fluffing.
And who is the straight male in my
cage and all this kind of stuff.
Drive him away. He flies back
so fast to clean house. Yeah.
So this is called the widow hood method.
And yes, it is a powerful motivator.
Yeah, they missed the misses. So
wow. So who knows how he did it,
but what may have propelled GI Joe
through those darkened war-torn skies was
jealous. Rage. Could have
been, could have been.
You go judge or you go get that young
buck [inaudible] you go gho and if you
have to save a thousand lives in
the meantime, okay, just do it.
[inaudible]
he good? Pretty good. Those pigeons.
But I think we can go one more around
for the human being and our natural
ability to navigate. I met,
uh, a woman named Lira Borucki.
She's in the psychology
department at Stanford University.
She studies languages and she's found
that some languages have a curiously,
I don't know how to put this a curiously
pigeon like [inaudible] no, seriously.
They're languages that don't rely
heavily on words like left and right.
And some languages actually don't have
those words at all. Um, in the, uh,
culture, I got to spend some time in,
they rely on north, south, east, west.
Oh, you mean like sort of taking
in left at the biscuit factory.
I'm going to hang in east
more so than that. Uh,
you would say things like, there's
an ant on your southwest leg,
or move your cup to the north northwest
a little bit. Where are we taught?
You should back up. This story is
too good. You should start at the,
where are we in the world right now?
This is a community called pump
morale on Cape York. In Australia.
When was this? Uh, this
was a few years ago,
I guess 2006 there.
The way you say hello in
pumper out is you say,
which way are you going?
Uh, so in English you say,
how are you fine in pumped I you
say, which way are you going?
And the answer must be something like
north, northeast in the middle distance.
How bout you say, imagine as
you're walking around your studio,
each person that says hi to you,
you have to report your
heading direction to them.
So you literally can't get past hello in
this language without knowing which way
you're facing.
And you said North northwest in the middle
direction isn't really that precise.
It's actually more precise than that.
There are 80 some different choices.
Yeah, it was socially very awkward.
People thought I was quite dim because
I wasn't oriented and I didn't know
exactly which way was which all the time.
It was especially notable when I was
surrounded by a small children who unlike
me, knew which direction
they were facing always. Yup.
You can ask a five-year-old
there, can you point northeast?
And they'll point without hesitation if
you ask a Stanford professor or Harvard
professor to do the same thing,
they have no idea. And I,
you know what if you were indoors, like
what if you were in a, in a shoulder?
Yup. They keep track of directions
even when they're indoors.
Without windows you'd pay attention.
You just have to pay attention.
And I think what's really
striking about, um,
the discovery of language is like this
and folks like this as they have an
ability that we call dead reckoning.
And it's an ability to, you know,
after any kind of circuitous path to
turn around and head straight back home.
That ability we thought
was beyond human capacity.
We had observed it in ants and
we had observed it in birds,
but there was always
some other explanation.
Like birds have magnets in their beaks
and ants are counting steps and you know,
there's some kind of extra
thing that they were doing.
Now there's 7,000 languages in the world,
about a third of the world's
languages have this property,
not a third of the world's speakers,
but a third of the world's languages.
And these are not folks that have
magnets or special aunts superpowers.
They, they're using this the same
cognitive system that we're using.
They're just using a differently,
they're paying attention to something
that we normally don't pay attention to.
But interestingly, earlier
it says there was a moment,
a very particular moment when she sort
of, she slipped into attention. Yeah.
So I had this interesting
experience and I was there.
So after about a week
of being there, I was,
people were constantly pointing, uh,
two locations and I was constantly
trying to stay oriented.
And after about a week,
I was walking along,
I was kinda trudging through
the sand. It was hot.
And I was thinking about whether I
was wasting my time there or not.
I wasn't sure if this study was going to
work out and all of a sudden I noticed
that in my head there was this extra
little, it seemed almost like a win,
like an extra window,
like in a video game there was like a
little console and in that console was a
birds eye view of the landscape that I
was walking on and I was a little red
dot. That was traversing
that landscape. No kidding.
And you just become a pillow ball
allo or whatever they're called them
and I thought, wow, that's really cool.
That makes it so much easier if you have
that little extra module in all of a
sudden is the correct word. Is that you?
It happened all of a sudden it, yeah,
I just saw it. It was,
it was just there and then I kind of
shyly shared this with someone. I said,
you know, this weird thing happened.
I was walking along and I got this,
I had this view in my mind and they
looked at me kind of strangely and said,
well, of course. How else would you do it?
That's exactly of course you have a
bird's eye view and you keep track of your
location from a bird's eye
view. Of course you do.
I have that all the time. No,
you don't. You really don't
proceed to break. And by the way,
bad voice right there that's been
joining us from time to time. Uh,
we should explain that. Is Karen Jacobson
also known as the GPS girl.
She was nice enough to agree to read
some things that we could use in our
stories. So that's what you been hearing.
Okay. Well shall we start with the
scripts that I have in front of me? Okay.
Please enter your address.
Well, that's amazing.
It sounds like you've actually
gone into the machine somehow.
Are you someone that gets lost a lot?
No, I have a great sense of direction.
Years before I did the voice of gps,
I was on vacation with my family in
Denmark. We were in this little town,
it was winter, it was
getting dark, it was raining,
and then the street signs were in
Danish and we didn't speak Danish.
And I am still heralded as the family
member who navigated us out of that
situation cause it was like around
and round there in this little town.
But who ever would have imagined that
ended up being the person giving people
directions in millions of
cars all over the world.
Can you do that? Can you do the, can
you go into character again? Yeah.
Okay. Yeah. Proceed north,
northwest in the middle distance.
How about you?
Wow. [inaudible] had a
bundle that, oh, I did.
Okay.